this podcast and every other podcast on
my channel is brought to you by my
supporters on patreon they get content
early completely ad free and extra
content mostly they are the reason that
i am able to support so many shows with
so many cool people and chat to more and
more game developers so if you want to
support this kind of content please
check out the patreon the link is in the
description hello everyone and welcome
to another episode of video game writing
101 today i am joined by thomas and
louis thomas who are you and what do you
do
so my name is thomas jabo and i'm the
world director on nine night two well
that's been released a couple of months
ago now
and i'm still working at techland and
something i can't really talk about but
uh which let's say is the continuation
of what i've done on later cool uh louis
how about you
yeah my name is louis manalo i am
my title is senior narrative lore master
yeah
yeah right it's impressive sounding cool
still trying to figure out what it means
but no but i'm at a i'm at shark mob in
malmo sweden
um i mostly work on uh what unannounced
project but i also did a little bit of
work of writing work actually on
uh vampire the masquerade blood hunt
which comes out later this month yes
congratulations i i worked with somebody
who wrote on that
very excited for it to come out um so
let me start with you thomas and i'm
gonna be very interested i think to see
how much your jobs differ because you
both technically like at my studio would
be on the narrative design team in
theory
um but i imagine you do very different
things so so thomas what exactly is your
job
oh that's a hard one so that's how this
one i always have trouble defining the
job well would you define yourself as
being a part of the narrative team
um no because we have a narrative
director or his name is humanik so he's
the one who's really directing the
narrative my my job is
really to be
uh the one who uh obsesses about the
world so it's very it's like a lot of it
is is driven by the narrative so it's a
it's a lot about you know uh what what
you hear the people say in the world
uh but it encompasses kind of everything
and the funny thing is when i started at
techland you know people were coming to
ask me basically
all sorts of questions about level
design about art about all kinds of
stuff because world director it's kind
of like okay it's the world so it's kind
of a bit of everything
uh but really like if i had to define it
it's more like acting like as glue
between between the different uh
directors sooner so you work with a lot
of different departments i work with a
lot of people i work with a lot of
direction but let's say
my uh
my i'm more like a narrative flavor
in me
because i because that's where i come
from um and actually luis and i worked
on on uh on ghost recon violence when we
first worked together i was senior
narrative designer on this team
uh so this is where i come from you know
story and and crafting story is kind of
it's kind of uh
you know what what what what what really
moves me and what really makes me tick
uh and you know the thing is like for me
it's like it's like a good story if you
don't believe in the characters then you
can't you can't buy the plot you can't
believe the plot so it's kind of the
same for the world like you have to
believe uh in the characters that
inhabits this world uh to believe in the
world that they're in so it means like
you have to find that you have to like
figure out their stories and and believe
in in in their stories and and
and this is when you believe uh
in in the world so for me that's that's
one of the main job is like how do we
make how do we how do we give life to
the people that inhabit this world you
know like yeah that's a world that's
nice there's principles post apocalyptic
it's the city and everything but like
what are the human stories that are that
are behind it and for me it's what it's
you know it's what i really
i think was kind of lacking when i when
i arrived at techland and i i try to put
a lot of energy in that it's like i want
these little stories i want these little
details i want i want to you know
because because this is what makes me
believe in in the world basically did
you also have a hand in
crafting the parts of the world and
dying like two that are like you know
how the street level is more barren full
of zombies and then the rooftops are
often more lush there are humans living
up there like is that something that
comes from your role or is that like a
level design
oh yeah so that's why it's tricky uh but
this this was this was like a something
that they had early on and even before i
arrived at this idea that you know like
rooftop is hope and and the street level
is death it was like a very clear
visual principle and organization
principle for the world that that really
worked well um so that that predated my
arrival let's say but i built on that uh
obviously you know like
of course the you know the
people are gonna live on the rooftop so
that's where they're gonna build their
life that's where the stories are gonna
happen and and we have some structures
and that's something that i i i pushed
was in the same idea to say like i wanna
feel life i wanna feel these people are
alive so one other thing i i pushed and
i led was
the abundant structure so we have
structures basically when you arrive in
the city that kind of ruins and you as a
player get a chance to uh to restore
these structures to make it simple uh
and they're on the rooftops and and the
way we the way we tackled this was to
say you know like what what you know if
we had to rebuild the civilization on
the rooftop what would we start with
and you know it's basically going to
like maslow pyramid where we're like
okay we need shelter and then and then
you you need uh the the higher levels of
the pyramid towards love and self
uh self expression so this this you know
putting life on the rooftops to make it
for short answer
was one of the thing i did but this was
a principle that they had before and
that was visual that was that was story
that was gameplay even
you just expanded on it to give it more
life yeah yeah exactly makes sense um so
louis same original question to you like
what exactly is your job how would you
describe what you do
okay so
uh right now you know because it's a
new ip yeah so basically you know the
loremasters
job normally is to write sort of like
the background of the world and
character biographies and stuff like
that so that's definitely like a big
part of it um you know that's kind of
sorry it's not because again like this
is unannounced i don't want to like give
away too much totally absolutely no
question
yeah but you know i like a kind of early
stage of a game of an ip
basically it's definitely a lot of
collaboration so like every day we're
talking with like concept art we're
talking with level designers and other
things but basically like with every new
ip
what you do is you basically you need to
write the rules of your world you know
what i mean so that's kind of the like
the stage that we're at now with all the
different teams like especially also of
course with game design you know sort of
defining all the different things that
can happen in our world like who the
player character is a lot of these
different things like that i mean lewis
that sounds even by itself very
difficult like as somebody who is
working on a franchise that has i don't
know 12 entries or whatever like god of
war's been gone for for a long time
things change so much that sometimes it
can be hard to track things i
i feel like working on a new ip must be
very challenging especially if you're
the person expected to keep it
consistent well again it's not obviously
it's not just me yeah that's true like
there's like the the ip director and
narrative director martin hoelberg's
there and um
and then also uh the other lore mastered
uh jimmy williamson so like it's kind of
what's
interesting about it for us is because
it's all new like basically we need to
also organize it all as well there
whereas if we were working on vampire
the masquerade like that stuff there's
like literally like 20 books it goes
back
to like 90 by like the mid 90s early mid
90s you know that franchise and then of
course there's all the the fandom that
comes with vampire the masquerade as
well so like like even like i wrote like
one quest in
and blood hunt
and even just that like trying to keep
track of all the rules of like what's
already been established and then i was
always like asking like the
you know the main writers of it so so
what would the fans actually like
there's things like that so
but your
job right now if i can ask like what
what what are you what are you doing
like tomorrow like again
holiday weekend holiday weekend
don't get time off for easter in the us
yeah yeah i know but now i but we have
off to like tuesday you got that in
australia too this country's so
religious i'm infuriated so you're
you're taking tomorrow well you're in
california so that's different basically
like
in texas you'd have like yeah right
maybe i don't know it's but it's not the
fact that it's not a public holiday
anyway i'm very upset about it obviously
um so on tuesday probably what are you
doing
again like i can't like say
too much stuff but like at this point
um at this point like i'm wearing a lot
of hats so um obviously
my background
is much more from the script writing
side uh in games anyway so you know like
when i was working to miles uh
a writer on wildlands and then became
lead writer on ghost recon break point
um
so
that's kind of i'm always kind of
tackling
the the new er any project basically
kind of from that angle
so sort of looking at what the needs are
from
like the writing workflow and things
like that so because you know like
i'm basically already have like scoped
out what kind of writing work needs to
be done
even if you know we're not really like
writing scripts yet at this point you
know what i mean i'm still sort of
saying like where things are yeah so
right now i suppose lewis you're you're
at a point where it's mostly like
writing the the back story the bible
kind of like character bio yeah at this
point basically we've we've approved
like a lot of that stuff is basically
like going to approval you know what i
mean so uh obviously rewrites you're
going to be coming
uh and things like that but then they're
still
you know like kind of you write all the
backstory and bios and stuff you have to
see where it hits the road in terms of
level design and game design and stuff
so and then you send it off to an artist
and you get art back and you see it's
the coolest thing ever and then you get
a new idea and everything
it's not always it's not always like
that
yeah yeah it's not always
yeah no very often yeah it depends on
where it is so like again some other
studios
like well not and not some other
students but in many studios like it
starts with the art you know what i mean
like
at
where you're at they probably started
with the drawing of kratos before they
decided what they were going to do you
know kratos originally had a different
name
yeah there were loads of things that
like originally were very very different
uh i don't i don't wish i could remember
what it was like damascus or something
like that
um but they ended up changing to kratos
which i feel like was probably a good
call definitely went through a lot of
changes in any case
um
but yes that that makes sense uh thomas
compared to like you know i'm working on
i think there are actually that there
are
nine games in the god of war series
lewis is working on uip you're working
on a or have worked on a sequel
but it's also a different character
yeah
and
yeah well i was gonna say you also
joined the project slightly later in so
like what what what do you like try to
think about when you're crafting a world
for a sequel specifically obviously
everyone says in marketing bigger and
better but like if we're talking about
the actual dev perspective like what is
the goal or did you think about it or
did you just try to make something new
and fresh
wait and to be honest like the project
that had been in development for quite a
while so when i when i arrived there was
a lot of like ideas everywhere and there
was there was a lot of documents and
there was a a lot of a lot of a lot of
content on a lot of servers and i
suppose that's kind of a classic
uh but then they had they still had like
a few
like some some very clear principle for
the ip you know the day and night cycle
that that that stuff i told about i told
i talked about before which is uh this
this uh this um
this breakdown between uh street uh
level which is death and and the rooftop
that is hope and they also had this
modern uh dark age idea which was pretty
pretty pretty powerful and driving a lot
of choices but to be honest one of the
first thing i did when i arrived was
kind of like to soak in all the content
yeah
you know you're talking about god of war
being being uh nine nine different uh uh
i
was reading it for a long time
yeah so i joined
so so so same for me and and i wasn't
familiar with the the franchise i i
briefly played the night uh but you know
it's kind of like before joining the
company that i that i really got into it
and it was a really good surprise
uh but the first thing was like getting
getting acquainted was like everything
was around and then the thing is like it
was also at this point my role because
we were like one year before
before gold basically so it was also
working with uh with my boss the cco uh
to
to make choices basically because at
this point a lot of you know it's like
it's like a tree
and there's all these branches and then
they're all looking nice and they all
have flowers but some are dead and
you're not really sure which ones and so
you're like okay we should cut this we
should cut this branch and we should
make sure that we have like one one one
timeline for example like uh one
backstory of the world that wasn't there
or like one
backstory of the night runners who are
kind of like the uh let's say the secret
order uh that that you join or not
actually in the main game and so a lot
of it was about
if i'm
just talking about
you know just just the game just
downloaded to just the sequel itself was
trying to sort out uh you know what was
still
valid it was still uh
gonna make it to the game and and just
like have one canon version and actually
it's one of the first thing and i mean
it took me three months three and a half
months uh but one of the third thing i
came up i came out i came up with was
this world bible so it's basically this
like over 100 pages document that is
like all right so this is the fantasy
this is the world this is this is uh
uh this is the themes that we are
tackling in this game and and then this
is everything about the how the world is
structured like this is the backstory
this is the events that happened uh this
is what the city vildor is and was
before the fall and what happened in
between it's kind of like a it was like
almost an
archivist job
yeah for some of it but you know like
like a crossover between being archivist
and and like uh creative uh uh you know
creatively
uh bringing bring this this ip into all
right this is what there's one truce and
this is it and you know nothing else and
and this is this is not valid anymore
this is the this is the canon
thing and and this helped basically
all the teams focus and make sure
you know that's what described when you
asked me what did you do well there's
not one
short answer except like being the glue
between between all the directions
uh to be fair nobody i've had on the
show that i've asked a similar question
to has ever
had a succinct answer uh nobody said oh
well i write um everyone's like media a
lot of departments um like it it is i
think so much more varied than maybe the
public i'm writing some stuff on papers
yeah all right
one of the ways that i i think about it
which is especially now since it's like
a lot a lot of it is also like ip
building is that
the narrative is at the beginning of the
game but it's also at the end you know
what i mean so like
you know you're right like tomas do and
you're creating the world and everything
and all the rules and then
i mean it's it really is like how the
workflow goes so then you know like you
said then okay there's art then there's
missions and then there's you know
gameplay and stuff i mean often
you know gameplay much involved in the
beginning as well of course but then
like you're also there at the very end
when you're writing the dialogue which
is in with the actors and things and
then very often you're also involved in
the marketing as well yeah you know and
then like based off of the audience
responses and what you had planned you
also decide where the franchise goes
you're well you're you don't decide but
it's a narrative topic where the
the
story goes next you know so yeah
but uh yeah so so a lot of it is like
also giving uh
everyone a set of constraints you know
creative constraints not like
you know in a negative way but helpful
ones for sure
it's like the play field it's like this
is this is this is where we're playing
and and this is what we want to achieve
and and and you know it's like it's like
the it's
the the the prism through which everyone
is going to do their job afterwards so
very long answer again sorry but no
it's good
this is this is uh this is what i
started doing and this is this was my
first thing working on on 992 and then
if we're talking about the franchise and
where where teklan wanted to take the
franchise you know i think that there
were some stuff that they were
definitely sure you know like for
example the parkour experience and so
it's like really the the core of the the
it's what makes this game tick you know
like it's it's it's what it's what it's
what you it's where you reach the flow
is when you are parkering on the rooftop
and you know chaining the different
moves and stuff so that was something
that they knew was like they had struck
gold and that this is the thing that
they wanted to expand
so one of the core uh a pillar of the
second one was
natural movement and expanding this
experience and what goes with that is
you have on one side you have you know
the gameplay the movement the the three
c's what happens when you have the pad
in hand and on the other hand you have
the playground so the the the one of the
strong uh first driver to create this
game was we need an amazing playground
just for fun for play that is going to
fit that and there's going to for which
you're going to be able to basically
have fun with this with the story of the
parkour um so so that was the stuff that
they that they that they that you know
was a initial constraint and then
obviously like
having a deeper world having having a
playground that is not only fun but also
makes sense that also has different
layers of complexity you know it's
something i'm very personally like super
attached to like this
breadcrumb things like you know like you
you you have several layers to this
world you have the obvious you have what
the quest givers are telling you you
have what you see on the wall
literally um
and then you have a second layer that
that is more like once you play a little
bit you understand the organization you
understand the dynamics in this world of
the factions or some big events and then
if you really scratch if you really
scratch the the surface really deep then
you have this third layer which is which
is going to be detailed which is going
to be stuff that you hear in
collectibles which is going to be stuff
that you hear when you heaves drop and
some of the other npcs there and which
will which will give you like the last
uh part if you're obsessed about this
game uh if you're obsessed about again
which will give you the last uh
uh
you know like pieces of the puzzles so i
i
i really i love this kind of stuff like
that very important and it's it's it's
an interesting one to talk about because
i feel like a lot of people like general
public probably don't even know that
your job exists but it's something that
is so important to giving players a
cohesive world and i i wanted arsenal
lewis obviously touched on caring about
what fans think in terms of like
vampires um did you watch streams when
dying light 2 came out did you watch
people play it to see their reaction to
you know all those pieces that were put
together
yeah yeah of course yeah it's like it's
the first thing that you do i mean uh
you know of course like uh yeah you've
been there so you know like you first
thing you google frantically and f5 f5
f5 f5 but you also like
kind of like kind of like uh
uh
check the stream check the you know
mainstreamers you you check the fans you
also like i had specific stuff that i
was you know like
proud of like these camphor storytellers
just little scenes that happen in the
open world and you don't have to do you
know you don't have to participate in
them but just like they're just little
stories that you hear and there's a lady
singing
and for me there were a moment of poetry
in this world because you know okay with
sick world and you have this contrast
and i was like super for me it was like
this
it's something from the heart and and
and and uh you know like seeing the
direction of some of the players lots of
players were like what what is this like
where do i get to slash zombies in these
things and you're like
all right
some people really liked it and some
people were like you know like i
appreciate that you put this extra touch
to to give life to the world like it was
saying before it's like i put a lot of
thought into that opening area in dying
light too where they've clearly had the
party
yeah you see that people are just like
dead holding their drinks like even that
i was like oh wow like what was this
person doing like even even something
like that you see really early on like i
ended up being like oh this is wow these
people kill themselves oh my god yeah
folks at tech clans are really talented
at
coming together with with these little
stories that you can read in the
environment and yeah like big kudos to
the to the environment artist uh art
director kasha tarnatzka and and to all
the other artists because they're really
they're really great at that so you know
something that like uh there was a
twitter thread from one of the artists
on halo infinite who spoke about how he
was placing specific kind of scenes to
like oh we want this to look like combat
training and like oh maybe this is like
these people you know got murdered it's
stuff that's not necessary but that
somebody really enjoys doing it's such a
cool touch to a world for sure so lois
i'm assuming your answer is the same but
do you
like youtube videos of things when
they're released
no sure like um well for something that
tomorrow and i shared was uh and the
reaction to ghost recon wildlands which
is like
for a lot of people you know it's just
like okay i'm gonna go shoot things
drive around and blow stuff up but then
there are like you know some real like
dedicated fans who like
really dug deep into the lore and that's
what i liked about
you know about what you can do with the
medium is that like you can actually get
like very deep in the narrative if for
the players that want it you know but
you just you know but if the players
uh yeah you can't opt in with other
creative mediums really like you can't
opt in with the movie you've just gotta
watch the whole thing
yeah like kind of kind of i mean the uh
you know it's also you know just like uh
how much you want to read into the thing
as well
you know what i mean so it's kind of uh
yeah it's it's still like a very cool uh
like marshall mcluhan cool kind of
medium as well you know what i mean
where like i wonder if there's anybody
who exists in game dev who doesn't watch
youtube videos or streams or whatever
like when the god of war ragnarok
trailer came out i was watching them for
like a day
just watching people react and like
seeing some people cry and it was the
the people who um knew the names of all
the characters was what got me it was
like the people who were like this
character you're like you're really into
this that's awesome it's very in blood
hunt as well because they had we had
early access uh like uh late last year
so they were definitely like people who
were really into it and there were also
people who were
like kind of new to the
franchise you're also just discovering
as well so that's also cool to see too
you know yeah it's super cool so i'm
gonna pivot away from
both of your actual jobs now into like a
question that i like asking people
i guess you can answer it either way are
there games that you think have done
your job incredibly well like games that
you find to be particularly inspiring or
then the second part would be like what
what the direction would you like to see
the industry head in
um what are things that you would like
to see more of all the things that i
guess generally really inspire you
i'm sorry i did not prepare you for this
question in advance go ahead tomorrow
okay thank you
no yeah for me
[Laughter]
no but for your first question i i uh i
have
for me and my polish
co-workers are going to be proud of me
because i would say which three is uh
probably it's probably the game that
impressed me the most in terms of
building the world
uh and and the reason for that is one of
the things that we were talking on
before at least to me i mean i'm sure
we'll have plenty of comment that people
have different opinion but for me
what struck me about this game is the
consistency the consistency of of of of
its world you know like it's got a few
themes that it it taps in like the
fatherhood you know the war and this
kind of thing and you consistently have
like different
uh different ways to uh to look at at a
problem or to look at this this topic of
fatherhood for example which is which is
uh something like you have the red baron
quest that's talking about you know the
the child that is
this this monster and of course the
story of siri and uh and and geralt this
is
is is uh you know is about father being
not being a father being a father uh and
and what i loved about this world is
that everywhere if you if you search the
world you will find something that
resonates in in one way or another with
one of the themes uh and it's just like
for me like either way i see it is like
a tapestry it's like tapestry of bayou
you know like this thing like this
fresco that has all these little pieces
that come together
uh and after
50 hours or 250 hours like me
then you you you drop the pad and you're
gonna remember this thing you know
you're gonna remember some of the
moments because they make sense with the
the overall your overall experience so
it's it's i don't know how they you know
like i i i we have some people from
former cd projekt people so maybe i
should ask them but you know for me i
had a feeling that there was this this
really strong
[Music]
you know vision that they all kind of
like
knew
how to tap in it and also from a
production standpoint or from a
game-making standpoint the thing is like
you don't only want to have a vision as
a director as a world director as a
creative director the idea is also how
do you how do you empower people to
bring their own you know brick to the
wall
if that makes sense yeah
which means like
what's you know what would be your take
of talking about the world and talking
about the war or talking about
fatherhood in a world like the witcher
as an artist as a sound designer as a
gameplay programmer
and i think they they made an amazing
job as that and of course the writing uh
the writing and the stories in uh in
which the three are you know one of the
best uh best in class so that also helps
you know believe in the world believe in
the stories of the people
one of the best games ever made i
strongly agree yeah so shortly
good answer uh louis how about you
so i kind of keep going back to two
different games
well
when it comes when if it's a game like
yeah there are two different games that
are kind of that are actually similar
in ways that but people don't ever think
of them that way and the first one is
mafia 3
and even though like whatever like
criticisms people have of it um very
often people criticize the gameplay and
stuff but i feel like the way that it
tackles character and politics
especially the race politics at the time
in history it's actually like very
you know deep and it took a lot of risks
with a lot of the stuff that it was
doing you know like one of your like
like main like the friendly npcs is like
a black panther you know what i mean and
then yeah
i really should like yeah yeah no
because there is also kind of um
and this is sort of how and in certain
ways it's actually similar to breath of
the wild which is kind of a strange kind
of comparison didn't see that coming go
on yeah but you know like oh
well yeah you gotta explain now louise
yeah so like in breath of the wild you
have like a lot of choice and
everything's really player driven you
know what i mean and i love like if you
want to talk about where narrative needs
to go that's that's where i feel it
needs to go but like so for example in
breath of the wild
you can go to your three different like
big robot bosses before you go to the
main boss you know what it means you
have these sort of choices
the world reacts to that but then also
the same thing happens in mafia 3 it's
just that because there are different
territories you can choose to take over
and you choose which one you take over
first and then depending on like how you
play these things out like there are
different like branches that happen in
that one as well
so like they're yeah so that's
you know like so they're basically like
you know obviously like dying like two
has this too or like you know you decide
you know like who gets the water i said
you know what i mean so like these kind
of choices that chan where the player
has uh
has a uh an effect on the world that's
also fed back to the player you know i
mean like this is the kind of thing that
this is where story needs to go so where
it's the player is basically like
they're writing their own story they're
kind of co kind of co-writing their own
story you know what i mean in this in
this world that all the developers have
made
so i would assume that you agree with
that thomas
if we're talking about the direction we
want to see narrative heading yeah
absolutely absolutely and this is this
is
you know one of the it's the the tech
itself is quite impressive like it's one
of the
this choice and consequences thing is
like there's really this ability to in
dynalite 2 and in the engine
uh
the sea engine there's this ability to
have like basically different
versions of the world that will that
will you know
be what you experience as a player uh
with your choices so yeah i agree it's
it's it's a tricky thing because you
know like
uh the thing is like you want
choices to be meaningful and you don't
want it to be like an ever expanding
like an infinite tree of choices of
things that don't really matter you know
like uh for me ironically there's also
one thing is like
one other thing i i like the authored
approach as well i like the fact that uh
that uh this this witcher 3 for example
is built with this intention and that it
makes me feel like it makes me feel
something because because they've put
the
the
everything to create this emotion uh in
me so
um
this is where i'm like um
uh
you know
in between like the the choice is yes
but if the if they are meaningful and
they really bring something as a player
that is like a a different a different
experience from what you lose if you
make different choices you experience or
you elana if you make different choices
that you experience
so
yeah
it's just that it's difficult like this
is a thing that seemingly everyone i've
spoken to has agreed on and i feel very
strongly about it too which is like the
idea of video games really taking
advantage of being video games rather
than being more like movies and and
figuring out the tech that makes that
easier but i think that it probably is
more difficult than the general public
thinks that it is to make
branching
do it no for sure but i think i think a
lot of the response is like why didn't
you just do this it's like
well i mean
could either of you shine some light on
what makes that uh more complicated than
than people think
i mean
you know like it's it's uh
it's simply because it's exponential if
if um
you know if
as soon as you start to have like a
couple of choices or three choices or
four choices that you can make then it
just becomes like this like i said this
infinite tree of possibilities of
different scenario different situations
and just in terms of content it's hell
so you know you have to make content
converge at some point you have to make
these choices content these choices
converge at least in in the current
approach and you know another approach
could be to say like you change the
rules so you you change some parameters
in in the way the game is playing with
your choices which then becomes
something that is a little easier to
tackle because you're not necessarily
creating new content or new characters
or new dialogues and that kind of stuff
but you are
basically adding a modifier that is you
know
you know the an easy example is like um
if you uh
if you
um
if you have uh this idea of trust with
with a character so when you talk to him
he's going to have like different way of
answering you that are based on your
trust level so that's something that you
can kind of like modulate and even
through through let's say software but
as soon as we're talking about content
creation and like custom dialogues
custom scenes custom
assets then
it's it's it's a it's a hell for for for
production you know these yeah choices
so yeah what what tomah is saying i
think a lot of it is also the approach
to narrative it's it's still very linear
yeah and most studios so even a
branching
narrative is a linear narrative it has a
beginning and it has an end or maybe it
has several lines but that's still very
linear you know whereas like
like if you look at a game like
minecraft that is completely that is
narrative it's just that it doesn't have
like as many voice lines as other things
you know what i mean but the proof is
like my kids are addicted to minecraft
novels you know what i mean like even
didn't even know those existed no max
brooks who wrote world war z he even
writes them really no no no oh my god
yes so it's yeah so yeah senator mel
brooks is writing minecraft novels
because that's like how
that's how much people are and players
are invested in these narratives that
they write themselves wow you know what
i mean so they're basically all these
different rules have been set up by you
know mojang or whomever and then the
players you know they write their own
stories in them you know what i mean
yeah like breath of the wild like you
were saying it's a kind of similar thing
you're writing your own stories and i
think even the witcher 3 does do that to
an extent where you remember it because
of the hand that you had in it where you
were emotionally at the time what you
were feeling that day then it becomes a
thing that lives with you forever kind
of which is a
beautiful thing about video games i mean
the cheapest stories are the stories the
player tells himself in his head you
know and that's like a book you know and
and for me and it's also the one i
remember the most and it's the one that
uh maybe because of our job i guess
we're more sensitive to that or more
sense sensitive to that uh but it's it's
you know it's the best stories it's the
one where you
you're not told everything you're not
shown everything but you you create the
stories out of some like you were saying
environment storytelling like you make
the story oh my god these guys were
training or they died or they did
something you know yeah
for sure
um okay for my last question because we
did have to start later i won't keep you
guys too much longer
just pivoting very different direction
here that's pivoting today elena just i
gotta get all my bases here
this is the hottest of the pivots um for
anyone who would be interested in doing
what you do for a living what advice do
you have how do people don't
do it
no it's like no seriously like do do not
do it it's like
no because it's like it's the yeah
it's like one of the most
like
like it you you hate it's like a
heartbreaking thing that you
don't you know it's like being in a
in a romance with somebody who you hate
you know you can never switch off that's
the thing that i always think about is
like the jobs that my family have and
then they go home and then they don't
think about work
never
never you but you you you meant to do
this elena that's the sign of me so i
was like i wish i was i wish i was an
accountant you know and i don't have to
worry about you know like night about oh
my god what's gonna happen to the scene
what's gonna happen with this guy but
you love it oh yeah i do i like that it
consumes me even if i think sometimes it
would be nice to not watch a movie and
go yeah interesting yeah yeah that's
horrible right because you're like oh
please stop seeing this yes everything
all the time other video games too right
but right but louis if i have to make
you answer the question yeah no no like
seriously so like i feel like
i mean that you know obviously
there are other like things so if you're
doing the actual writing thing
then
it has to be
there would probably be two things it
would be like read books like read
everything books but then also like do
your research
you know
so
yeah i don't know to my you uh
feel about that but
i mean
so i love what i do i'm sorry but uh
yeah yeah i mean i love what i do
um
but the thing is like it's it's uh we
briefly talked about it with lee was
before and i think it's like
um for me writing as a whole it's not
specific to a video game uh it's it's um
one of one of the best advice i've had
and i think it was in a true b book like
not everything's great about ruby but
this was for me good advice was to say
uh write something that changes your
life and it sounds like uh
like a [ __ ] marketing thing but it's
true actually and the reason
why for me something works is that let's
face it like most of the projects movies
books even games are not gonna
end or you know it's gonna take a long
time or you're not gonna finish it so
for me
if you write something that in yourself
in itself the topic or the thing that
you write about is something that uh
that you want in your life that you want
that that will change you as a person as
a professional as a creative as you know
just as
as an individual
uh then you've you've earned something
you've won something out of this
experience and uh
i've like i said like i told you i've i
wrote a couple of books and the second
one was never published
so you know like failure but at the same
time yeah
at the same time
you know
at the same time at the same time i
wrote about uh and the the the topic of
the book forced me to like dig into some
stuff that and that that really like
kind of like are still with me today uh
as a person you know so
uh i think it's i think
you know writes something that changes
your life because then it's also your
life it's also your life and it's what
you were saying just before by saying
like i wish i was an accountant
sometimes so maybe i said that but
it was the sentiment came back
yes
it was just i was i was just putting an
image to it and sorry for all the
accountants out there my mom is an
accountant my brother is an accountant
there you go it's close to home yeah
yeah so uh so anyway so if it if it
changes your life it also becomes your
life so it's gonna make you happy even
if your job is crap even if your work is
crap even if you don't make it even if
there are moments when you are like deep
down in this hole of like oh this is
[ __ ] you know like uh i hate like am i
just a failure and at least you you you
know like you you've learned something
and you can hang on to this thing
because you know it matters for you and
yeah
tangentials of that so i did um so like
uh colin mccann says something really
similar uh where he's like don't write
about what you know write about what you
want to know that's another yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
also interesting
i wrote a book about uh
very cliche but about a an ai
um and that advice did not work out
great for me because i ended up studying
for a year
uh and it just really delayed the
writing process like it just made it
very difficult to write anything because
i was like technically this is
inaccurate
like just to learn a lot about ai i
interviewed people
uh that is still not finished but i know
a lot about ai now so yeah so i i guess
kind of bridges the gap between uh both
our things right like the the research
part is also like super important stuff
and kind of like writing
about something that changes your life
or that you want to know i like both of
the both of the inputs you had um but
how do people get employed with those
inputs
they want to work on video games what's
the next step
so most people
who want to write for video games
they don't actually i think what they
actually want to do is is work in
like
marketing for video games actu to be
completely honest or because
once you get into marketing like most
people i know who are in who are working
like purely in ip and i like they have
like the people who have like ip
something in their title they come from
marketing
and uh in a lot of at least in aaa or
something you know what i mean so i i
think you know if you really want to
sort of like make like really
like uh
you know big decisions in terms of
storytelling sure do that but if you do
want to if you want to write clever
lines or something
uh
i'm probably the wrong person to ask i
mean i very much think that make sure
you know what you want to do is a very
good piece of advice because of the
amount of people that i've met in the 10
years that i've been in or around this
industry is a lot of people come to me
and say hey
i want to write but they don't they
don't like writing they just think that
writing is the easiest way to get into
something and there are definitely
people who do love writing but i always
want to be like would you want to be a
writer if it had nothing to do with
video games if not figure out the thing
that you are passionate about and figure
out where that fits in the industry
because there are so many jobs
so many positions that can do so many
things like if you actually really like
design you can even work in a design for
a website in terms of marketing like you
could start there but a lot of people
try to sandwich themselves into writing
because they think
that's the way to go despite having no
interest in writing otherwise so it's
definitely like
no way you can fit in the industry
rather than trying to fit yourself in
where you don't fit necessarily i think
you'll be happier in general it's like
just figure out two passions and shove
them into video games
i mean honestly i'm i'm often
sort of what you know like you're saying
people come up to you i'm often there
i'm often a little bit wary of people
who say well i want to write
because you can just start writing you
know what i mean there's nothing to stop
you yeah i had several screenplays and
short stories and things that i had to
submit that i didn't have to scramble to
put together for my submission because
i'd been writing them for 10 years yeah
so that was gonna be it was gonna be my
advice is uh you know like if you wanna
be a writer then right you know like uh
and that's that's the thing like uh all
the all the masters there's stephen king
in his books and everything they say
like if you want funeral write you have
to write every day it's like it's of
course like you can be your genius and
have inspiration but if you don't sit in
front of your computer and
type some words then nothing's gonna
happen and yeah a lot of the time the
words and the sentence is to be [ __ ] but
you know if you don't sit in front of
this computer and if you don't write
then nothing will be anything not [ __ ]
no nothing
so i think [ __ ] out of the way shit's
better than enough so then the good
stuff comes yeah [ __ ] so and and i think
you know like i i started in this
industry not on the creative side i
started on the production side actually
i'm an engineer by training so cool
writing yeah yeah
um it's a brag in france though
right
[Laughter]
but anyway so so
and and the fact that i've was writing
stuff on my
private time and i was writing you know
because i've always done that and i've
always it's always been something that's
been with me
then when the then the opportunity came
that you know there was this kind of
like spot or this opportunity to to jump
in and and
and go on a creative more creative
position
uh which happened for me
nine months ago nine years ago 10 years
ago that's a big difference
then then i had i sort of had the
credentials and it's not like even i'm
working for it because it's something
that i wanted to do so my best advice is
if you want to be a writer start start
writing some stuff if you want to be a
designer start designing some stuff if
you want to be a game player programmer
level designer you know open unreal open
unity like everyone can access it and
start doing some stuff even if it's [ __ ]
you know like that that that [ __ ] will
you know become
less shitty with with time you know look
at
look at uh
yeah look at i mean look at uh celeste
and uh forgot the name of the guy but uh
the guy
celeste is incredible
yes also the name of my daughter
uh
maddie
thornson wrote celeste and
noah barry was also a programmer yeah so
this
so this guy has been making like 30
games and he started when he was like 15
and of course the the
the 21st games were kind of [ __ ] but
then you know masterpieces so
it's made in four days during a game jam
what was celeste
what was it at least that would have
been initially yeah yeah i imagine a
concept came from that yeah prototype
yeah
yeah i also wrote my book i also wrote
my book in two days
no bragging really
no oh it was like [ __ ] five years
five [ __ ] years of my life that makes
sense now writing books is hard i have a
weird thing with publishing where i
think i need to get over it eventually
but i've written plenty of books um
i don't care about publishing them and i
don't know why but i have this weird
thing where i'm like i don't care i
wrote them i send them to my family and
i let some friends read them but i don't
care about anyone else reading them and
i know that i should know that i think
that's fine
yeah honestly no because if you think
about
so like the like the original
novel like tale of genji was just she
wrote it for her friends yeah
just wrote it for all these other
courtiers you know and i mean like i
think that's perfectly fine just it
feels weird people are always like why
are you gonna publish something and i'm
like when i care about going through the
effort to do that and find art and find
a published date and figure out where
it's going like i don't want to do any
of that so i'm just like what if i just
that's the thing no i think people are
getting away from like the whole purpose
of the thing like first cave paintings
weren't made for mass audience they
weren't made for people to see at all
ended up that way you know you made a
dark ass cave yeah that's true yeah so
it feels i feel like i'm broken because
i don't care but i still don't no it's
it's kind of stuck with the root of it
you know yeah i guess it's probably
easier for me to finish things because i
think there are probably some people who
try to write things with the intention
of publishing them and then that's a
very that's a difficult goal like you
need to have something emotionally
driving you or whatever to actually
complete a lot of stuff and the goal of
being published is probably one that
leads to some hollow writing
just make sure that this even care you
can do it just make sure after you die
someone will publish your stuff like
they did for
my friends
all right thank you both so much for
joining me today this is super fun and
and very interesting and you both do
very different things to a lot of the
other writers that i've spoken to so
extra interesting um does anyone have
any closing words anything else they
would like to add before we go
not really not really i think it was it
was really fun i love love yeah
no again i think again so yeah it is
difficult writing in games but or doing
narrative and games period but the best
part about it as opposed to writing
novels is the collaboration part of it
yeah you know so that's the thing so yes
i've
published fiction as well but it's like
the collaboration that you can get
like
getting ideas from all these different
people all the time like that's it's
there's it's so much better
honestly i find it a lot more rewarding
than you know like i love watching a
novel or like a story or something
working with people who are way way
smarter than me and have these areas of
expertise that i know absolutely nothing
about is the coolest thing in the world
it feels like such a privilege that i'm
like this person is an expert on this
thing they've been doing for 20 years
and i get to just ask them about it and
there's 600 of them like it's so so so
cool it's like i i agree with you that
it will take over your entire life and
it is very difficult in ways that i
think i probably didn't even necessarily
anticipate
um
in the year and a half i've been doing
it now it is it's definitely very hard
but it is super rewarding you know very
fun thing to do for a living and a fun
thing to talk about obviously
could do it for yeah
um is there anything anyone would like
to plug like something you're working on
right now obviously lewis you have a
game you worked on just about to come
out what date does it yeah
yeah it uh comes out
[ __ ] i'm gonna get
it wrong i think it's august 27th
yeah vampire the masquerade blood hunt
comes out
um
it's it it really is a lot of fun and uh
there have been a lot of changes that
made since uh
early access that i think
you know for
like old fogies like me who are
not like the best battle royale players
you know so it's a free battle royale so
of course like all the like kids that
play it and they're awesome and they
crush you but yeah
yeah so there are more features now that
that make it uh
uh more fun i guess uh for for people
who don't live breathe and
eat justice that royale yeah yeah so uh
thomas how about you
i mean to dying lights has been up for
two months now and uh
you know there's still we're still you
know tech lens make this promise to uh
to
support it for for five years so what
i'm working on is part of that support
uh plan so working really cool new
content
uh they just uh they just have or they
just they just release patch three or
will release it as citizens or something
but i mean you can join anytime in uh
dyna 2 and join the city and i hope you
know besides beyond this this amazing
you know parkour gameplay that is like
always a blast i also hope that you can
pick up some of the some of these little
pieces of of of this world of this lore
that are dear to my heart
and um
and if you do and i like it please uh
please please uh hit me on on twitter or
or tell them atlanta because we
we love it as developers people must
know like we are not robots we have
emotions and it's it's what we do it for
we do it for
you know players we do it for people
to to to tell us you know what they
think of a game so you know it matters
yeah unlike our novels which you just
write to hide
your friends
and i had said this in multiple videos i
think the world in dying light is one of
my absolute favorite things about it i
thought it was awesome
oh thanks elena i loved it thank you
very much where can people find you on
twitter that would be my last question
if anyone wants to reach out and has any
more
yeah so it's littlest littlest
thomas how little are you including this
um
fine fine average size
yeah yeah it's it's like i'm part of
these people who got twitter a long time
ago and got like a stupid name and stuck
with now yeah yeah you know and uh no i
no i have it i know it's like my
corporate or whatever
uh louis how about you all right people
find you
uh
you don't have to share if you don't
want to yeah no actually i don't have
twitter and uh bless you
save yourself
ah i'll see what ellen musk does with it
and then maybe i'll join
the first person to say that the whole
of twitter is like i don't want this
right now it's wild
all right yeah yeah yeah thank you very
much
we're all gonna basically ban right now
thank you both so much for joining me
thank you everybody for watching i'll
see you next time
[Music]
you